now two more ET moments with the one and
only Luke Perry you know no-show spent
more time with him at the height of the
nine oh two one oh hysteria only our
cameras joined Luke to learn what was
like for a day in the life of a TB hard
drive
[Music]
you were the Justin Bieber of 1991 how
does that make you feel real good
just how big of a star was Luke in this
et Canada interview he revealed that at
one event we had to be wheeled out
hidden in a laundry bin to escape the
crowds all I thought was my cars over
there yeah there are 20,000 people
between me and it there happened to be a
bin there I jumped in it threw the stuff
on
she just started pushing okay here we go
back in 1998 et spent a day in the life
of Luke tagging along as he jetted from
city to city meeting fans over the years
we've learned a lot of things about the
star he loved his family
Luke was never ashamed of the mullet he
rocked in the 80s he also told us why he
never joined social media you have
dyslexia and it's difficult for me to
deal with a lot of typing and numbers
and all that stuff going across the
screen so I just I just don't do any of
it and when it came to his status as the
crush for an entire generation I don't
think I'm that big of a deal I know he's
gonna reach me out the big cars and that
camera stuff it's really you know nobody
gets here by themselves it takes a great
deal of people yeah I feel very
fortunate and I just want to work hard
and I love what I do I'm glad
just a great guy and whenever we had a
chance to interact with him nothing but
fun and good times alright you know we
are hearing so many stories about how
nice and down-to-earth Luke was with his
fans case in point
these style photos fraud that he took
with our producers in New York Luke was
there to talk riverdale but he also hung
around the chat with everyone in the
office and look at the ladies I mean
they lost baram i know he was sweet i
had asked you me the best
[Music]